[MUSIC PLAYING]
Hi, folks.
My name is Justin McKay, and
I'm a product manager at AdMob.
So here we are at GDC.
Games today are amazing.
Incredibly rich,
immersive experiences.
On my phone, I can build
worlds, control armies,
or do things with birds.
Make them angry, help them
cross roads, help them fly,
things you'd really
think birds should
be able to do on their own.
But I digress.
As games have evolved, so
have monetization options.
Rewarded ads have been
one of the biggest
asks from our developer
friends for a while.
But if you're not familiar,
here's a quick refresher.
I'm playing a game, and I die.
I'm presented with a choice.
I can either wait
for 10 minutes,
or I can use my
hard earned coins,
recommend the game to a
friend, or watch a video
and come straight back to life.
When done well, rewarded ads
add value for all parties.
They are opt in,
integrated experiences.
So a quick recap on mediation.
Mediation allows you
to maximize revenue
by calling multiple ad networks
from a single platform.
This helps ensure
there is always
an ad to show in
your application
and that that ad is
helping you maximize
the amount of money you earn.
At AdMob, we want
to build a platform
to support all your
monetization needs.
Rewarded has been a
gap, and I'm really
happy to announce that,
today, we're closing that gap.
This afternoon,
rewarded mediation
is now available in AdMob.
So these seven great
networks, we're
adding these to the
40-plus networks
that we already support
through regular mediation.
This afternoon, Ad Colony,
AppLovin, Chartboost, Upsight--
formerly Fuse-- Fyber, and
Vungle are all available,
and I'm really excited to
say Unity Ads will be coming
in the next couple of weeks.
We want to make experimenting
with rewarded ads easy.
We want you to be
able to experiment
with different networks
and different orders
and different reward types.
As such, you can configure
reward and waterfall settings
for each ad unit.
That information is
stored server side,
so you don't need to change
your code to experiment
with new configurations.
And we want to give you tools
to maximize performance.
With our ad network
optimization product,
we automate the process of
calling the ad from the highest
paying network.
And optionally, you
can set frequency caps
to make sure your users
don't get bored seeing
the same ad again and again.
A little bit more about
ad network optimization--
so mediation on its
own isn't quite enough.
Across multiple networks, the
CPMs are changing in real time.
Managing that
complexity manually
is very, very difficult.
When you enable ANO,
AdMob will automatically
check which
network is paying the highest ad
and return that into your app.
This helps maintain a
high level of revenue.
So I'm really pleased to say
that four of the networks
are fully supported with
country level granularity,
and three more are
coming later in April.
So set up is really
straightforward.
As I said, we want to
give you the flexibility
to experiment with rewards.
When you're setting
up your rewards,
you can specify to use third
party settings that you've
put on another
network, or you can
set overrides that are
stored on the Google servers.
And you can also set
a frequency cap down
to the day, hour, or minute.
And, of course,
measurement is critical.
So you'll be able to
see in your reports
your rewarded queries,
starts, and completes.
So we are really, really excited
to bring this to you today.
We know it's been
a gap for a while.
We've been testing with
a number of partners
over the last quarter,
and I'm really
pleased to say
that they love it.
So we really look
forward to seeing
how the rewarded space
evolves, and we're really
looking forward to
working more with you
to get us feedback
on the product,
and I'm really excited to
see how it's going to evolve.
So thank you very much.
[MUSIC PLAYING]